we've talked before about
the amount of projection in american
politics and particularly among the
american right wing
if they are accusing someone of
something they are almost certainly
doing it themselves
in a fox news segment that is beyond
satire
trumpian republican congresswoman lauren
bober
says democrats are obsessed
with conspiracy theories check this out
here she is on judge jeanine pirro's
show
saying that no one on the outside can
get into the capital
only because of these conspiracy
theories that democrats are obsessed
with which has led to
national guard troops you know i
remember something happening on january
6
that explains why the national guard
troops are there i think there's real
questions about how long are they
staying
but i seem to remember something
happening there on january 6.
anyway here's lauren bober no one on the
outside can get into the capital
it is only staffers and and members of
congress
who are allowed at the people's
house at our nation's capital judge
jeanine this
is complete bonkers uh that we are
keeping
people out of the united states capital
there's clearly not a threat there was
nothing that happened on march 4th the
democrats are obsessed with conspiracy
theories and they won't let them go uh
we have a
border fence around the people's house
with miles of razor wire
and speaker pelosi wants to keep it up
she doesn't want a
southern border to protect us from
illegal aliens uh you know we have
biden and his handlers who aren't just
dropping bombs on foreign countries
they're blowing up our own agencies from
within they want to
render our immigration and customs
enforcement
useless and if they pass hr1 through the
senate
the democrats will have millions of
illegal voters some of them criminals
to help democrats keep the control in
2022.
now i genuinely don't know if anything
that she said there is true some of the
stuff is like
three or four layers removed from
reality
if democrats were to try to get more
undocumented immigrants into the united
states
it would have no impact on the 2022
election because undocumented immigrants
can't even register to vote
there has been think back to the 2020
election and all of their claims about
dead people voting people voting twice
all this stuff
they've barely even mentioned that
undocumented immigrants voted and
they've not even been able to
demonstrate that a single one did
and now she claims as if it's a foregone
conclusion
that the undocumented immigrants that
joe biden is supposedly letting into the
country
are all going to vote somehow in 2022
how do you even register to vote if you
are not a citizen of the united states
they never have an answer to that
question
and then understand the absurdity
of lauren beaubert saying it's democrats
obsessed with conspiracy theories bobert
is the one
who tries to bring guns into the house
and claims the conspiracy is with the
metal detectors
to try to disarm her she started her
campaign
fighting against the imaginary idea that
democrats were trying to
come and confiscate her guns beau bert
has previously expressed support for q
anon
but said she wasn't a follower just that
she hopes that it's true
these people make us a laughingstock
around the world and they don't even
know it
and if you were able to convince them
they wouldn't even care her followers
see this stuff and they believe it and
they're proud
to have her representing them she says
well
listen nothing ended up happening on
march 4th that's right
q anon thought trump would be
reinaugurated on march 4th
it was never going to happen there was
nowhere for them to go
the capital was locked down so of course
nothing happened but that doesn't prove
anything and notice
she doesn't bring up january 6th when a
very much
q anon enmeshed group of people
violently stormed the capital and
actually
very briefly delayed the counting of the
electoral vote this is a really common
tactic
with conspiracy theorists you deflect
by saying why are you so obsessed with
this conspiracy which i previously
promoted
you're more obsessed with q anon than
the people supposedly following you
maybe it doesn't even exist the way
tucker carlson said a couple weeks ago
saying
i couldn't even find an official q a on
website so i don't even know that it's
real
i don't see the lauren bobert story
ending well i think the most benign
possible ending
is she just loses in 2022 and goes away
or maybe knowing she's going to lose
chooses not to run
the other endings are all worse either
she gets re-elected and this type of
thing
becomes a bigger piece of our elected uh
house and senate
uh or she's involved in some insane
incident the likes of which i wouldn't
even want to speculate on that but i i
uh i'm not particularly optimistic
that the lauren bobert as an elected
official story
is going to end particularly well one of
our sponsors today is
helix sleep and it's a sponsor i'm
thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and they will pair
you with a mattress that will be perfect
for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within 100 days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video